when you think about the money studios
pour into your favorite films it isn't a
shocker that they may need to
occasionally reuse a proper a costume
still it can be jarring to see some of
these outfits which have been made
famous ones already in classic films pop
up again on some random extra wandering
around in the background here are a few
times movies got called recycling
costumes Dress for Success who can
forget that fabulous purple dress Clara
Clayton wore as she duck Brown and there
- weirdo kids ended the Back to the
Future trilogy by heading out on the
ultimate family road trip well it looks
like she donated the dress to a goodwill
somewhere along the way because the
character of Shannon in 1992's far away
came across the exact same dress in a
Boston storefront and just knew she has
to have it but while some dresses get to
travel through time others just can't
catch a break
that's one shipwrecked dress after
surviving the RMS Titanic collision with
an iceberg in the 1996 TV mini-series
Titanic this little black number on
actress Mary Lou Hannah found itself
right back on the doomed passenger liner
this time it was worn by actress
Treasurer O'Neill in the oscar-winning
1997 blockbuster Titanic talk about a
dresser needs a vacation preferably one
must doesn't end up at the bottom of the
sea
of course that's not the only outfit to
survive Neptune's west grass jacket
everlasting garments don't get much more
famous from this pink jacket worn by
Kate Winslet in 1997 Titanic which sold
at auction in 2016 for over 160,000
dollars and was actually made into a
doll and yet even this iconic outfit was
recycled it pops up again slightly
altered in the 2002 fantasy film a Turk
everlasting look guys that jacket has a
family to feed no judgments
helping Peggy else we figured out by now
period outfits often get reused again
and again if something works for one
1960 series it'll probably work just as
well for a movie set in the same
timeframe that was certainly the case of
this pink frock which Elisabeth Moss
wore in the Mad Men episode of three
Sundays only for it to pop up again in
the 2011 movie the help this time worn
by Anna camp the Hat of a hero
there's always a need for foppish hats
right whether you're a musketeer a
pirate or just a guy who happens to like
looking good this dandy number first
popped up in the 2001 flop of the
musketeer worn by future great Anatomy
star Justin chambers later the Hat
weaves its way to the Hollywood backlot
Sun onto the Magnificent mane of Orlando
Bloom for the 2003 smash hits Pirates of
the Caribbean curse of the Black Pearl
it just proves that old expression it
doesn't matter how bad the movie is you
just can't keep a good hat down or
something
Prince of garment thieves Alan Rickman
was a standout in whatever movie he
appeared in take his turn as a
villainous sheriff of nothingham in the
1991 action-adventure Robin Hood Prince
of Thieves he single-handedly saved an
ill-conceived project simply by being
capable of speaking with an English
accent his outfits were no less
extraordinary particularly this beaded
piece of black armour that showed up
again in both the French films of
visitors and on the back of the Queen's
advisor in Braveheart fashion hunter
when you're one of the fiercest bounty
hunters in the galaxy
you need gear that won't let you down
that may be why bask the Transocean
bounty hunter who appeared in a little
movie called at The Empire Strikes Back
lifted his outfit wholesale from an
astronaut and a 1966 episode of doctor
called the temp planet in fact the suit
originally came from the Royal Air Force
who used it as a high-altitude pressure
suit back in the 60s come to think of it
there's nothing more high-pressure than
taking on an angry wookie thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to